make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we're getting into unity saga
the the conclusion the first half of the
conclusion then is decided to split the
conclusion in half not really sure why
we decide to make it two parts here's
the funny thing about unity saga I like
it but it's kind of obvious that Bendis
is trying to figure it out as he goes
because it's basically like a handful of
story arcs that have all kind of been
folded into a singular event right and
that's one of the things he said he said
there like there's a lot of pressure in
writing Superman not really sure what
that pressure comes from because
Superman doesn't really sell that well I
guess maybe because it's just Superman
that's where the pressure comes from but
regardless of the circumstance what we
had you know and really in the beginning
of unity' saga is you basically had the
father of Superman you know jor-el
basically returning right it was like
okay what the world's going on and the
idea was I want to take your son and I
want to take him into the galaxy and I
want to show him what the legacy of
Superman means and so that's kind of
where Jonathan went then he just
disappeared and then he reappeared and
it was like okay so that's that's pretty
cool uh and then you basically go into
this idea that robos are of a villain
who I never really cared much about from
the Action Comics storyline I think
maybe it was the first arc in Superman
but they basically dealt with the fact
that like he had destroyed Krypton and
that there was this kind of ongoing
conspiracy among these various races you
know that led to Krypton's destruction
it was kind of an under you know ongoing
theme and then of course that runs into
Superman basically encountering rubbles
Oregon it kind of bounces all over the
place in reality this could have been
multiple story arcs but instead it was
all just sort of mashed together and for
Brian Michael Bendis that's par for the
course those of you guys that know
people that Marvel Comics will tell
those you guys who were at DC and you're
new to all this they'll tell you like
not really benefited from business being
on Superman because it's kind of hit and
miss it's kind of spotty sometimes and
that's that's the nature of his writing
and so what this does and this then and
we're gonna kind of like once we get to
the end of this part we're gonna run
into the biggest issue with Bendis but
what is up happening here because you
basically end up getting into this point
when you have Superman and you have
General Zod you have Supergirl you have
these characters who all basically show
up and and essentially like meet with
the thanagarians now what it does is it
kind of jumps back and it basically
picks up immediately after the last
video that we did where you essentially
have like the father of jor-el taking
Superman to Krypton is saying there's
something that you need to know
something that you need to see here and
it's kind of crazy because when this
happens you end up having Robles are who
shows up there as well now remember
robos are is a guy quote-unquote who is
responsible for Krypton's destruction
and General Zod
with him of course as we would expect
didn't really make a whole lot of sense
now in the previous video we talked
about that that it was all basically a
way for Zod to use raoult's law to
escape the Phantom Zone and then
ultimately turn against him and that's
exactly what it does it basically
presents the scenario for General Zod to
make his move because General Zod
immediately freaks out and starts
attacking attacking worlds are and the
reason why is because he's brought them
to Krypton right now under normal
circumstances you would say well this is
wrote this is General Zod reacting to
the fact that they're at like the
remains of his homeworld
right so it's like a desecration of
Krypton's memory to a degree that's
probably true the reality and the reason
why General Zod is freaking out is
because all that kryptonite radiation is
there right I mean they're they
basically flown into a field of space
filled with green kryptonite but it'll
essentially kind of at least it seems
like it'll doom them now rube Lazar
didn't really think about this he didn't
really anticipate this it was more of
just kind of like let's go to Krypton
because you know if jor-el has summoned
us here and so what it does is it offers
the opening for for Zod to make his move
to turn against Ruggles are and then
ally himself with Superman so it's
really kind of jor-el sort of taking
care of it all for him now it is
interesting in terms of how it unfolds
because this basically leads to Superman
trying to intervene right like trying to
step in and say like we have to do
something like I've got to get out there
and I've gotta get involved somehow but
the issue is again this is all just like
green kryptonite so long as he's there
so long as he's inside the ship he's
effectively safe but if he steps out and
he goes out into the vacuum of space
he'll to be exposed to all that green
kryptonite and his powers will start
sapping immediately and then he'll die
in in minutes if not seconds and so
wonder what jor-el does is basically
give him a kind of protection of source
so that kind of pseudo not really a suit
but like a shield of source that allows
him to go out into space and then the
grab General Zod and say like we have to
leave like we have to get out of here
because if we don't we're going to die
now the reality is that they want to
destroy robos are right that's the
intention is to eliminate robos are like
to destroy him to get rid of it because
for Zod he's the guy who led to the
destruction of Krypton for Superman he's
his major enemy now like there's only
only real way to stop czar is to get rid
of him to kill him off as it was kind of
a cool thing because what you end up
having of course is Superman you've got
General Zod and then you have Supergirl
who steps in along with Jonathan can and
and Krypto and they start taking it to
him right they start taking it to RO
bizarre and it seems like with the
intention of killing him the issue is
that they're immediately met by the
blackguard of the thanagarians now the
thanagarian blackguard is no laughing
matter
right
these are these are these are guys you
don't scoff at and anybody who knows
like all the fans of like Hawkman and
Hawkgirl who were like huge fans of
their mythos although tell you like the
Black Guard is legit like they're
they're pretty saw they're like the
elite fighting force they're the ones
that the thanagarians send out like when
things are popping off or when somebody
needs to be taken in there's way too
powerful basically and so with the Black
Guard of basically grabbing Superman
Supergirl Jonathan Kent and General Zod
in them and essentially like bringing
them into thanagar what you end up
having a Superman sitting down with
everybody and saying look here's the
problem right there's conspiracy here
like all the information we've
discovered over the years basically
shows us there's conspiracy with the
destruction of Krypton that a lot of
people were involved in the destruction
of Krypton
now this is when we starting to get into
really the events of like Supergirl
issue number 29 what's been going on in
that story and the reality in terms of
why Krypton was obliterated now this is
one of the things that that bindus
really got some backlash on the
destruction of Krypton and and his
father's attempt to save it it's kind of
like an absolute narrative right like
changing the basis behind the
destruction of Krypton really on a whim
that really sort of flies in the face of
over you know 70 80 years of comic book
history it's not something fans really
take lightly
right it's making like a massive change
and so as a result of that the way the
bidness played this out is he
essentially copied the the concept of
the Illuminati from Marvel and the idea
behind this is that in Marvel Comics you
had the yeah the Illuminati like Tony
Stark and and Doctor Strange Reed
Richards of the Fantastic Four Black
Bolt name of the Submariner Black
Panther you know going into Hickman's
run and Captain America originally then
I guess you know kind of removed then
you had Professor X but the idea was to
safeguard the earth from threats and to
do it secretly behind the scenes so
nobody knew that it was then what bindus
did is he created an organization called
the circle which composed of one of the
old guardians of the galaxy somebody
from the thanagarians a member of the 14
sons named and ello and she's really the
one responsible for all this right the
idea behind it was that the circle would
centrally function in order to keep the
peace across the universe writer I guess
across the galaxy or whatever space it
is that DC wants to reference and they
would do it secretly behind the scenes
and nobody would knew when nobody would
know what it was that they were doing
the issue is that gondola wanted to
basically eliminate worlds that that
that were considered to be world's it
would most likely bring war before they
ever became a problem in the first place
right to be exceedingly proactive like
Star
the problem before it becomes a problem
and so as a result of that what ended up
happening is Gandil Oh basically started
targeting all these different worlds
across the cosmos and and robos are was
a guy whose world was essentially
destroyed and so he was just this being
filled with hate and rage right so much
like the Red Lanterns you know I'm much
like Atrocitus and so the result of this
is that gondola basically started using
the robos are as a means to destroy
entire worlds and then if a time ever
came where it seemed like the circle
would be discovered they would absolve
themselves of all responsibility that
would point the finger at robos are and
say we don't really know what happened
this guy's a crazy guy we just didn't
catch him in time
and so that's the he was really just
kind of considered to be a fall guy and
so the result of that is that that
eventually led to the destruction of
Krypton because it was one of the
targeted worlds now again people didn't
really take kindly to that people were
counted pissed they were likewise Bendis
changing this right cuz that's the thing
bidden is just sort of picked things and
changes them for the sake of changing
them now having read comics for so long
I don't really care about things like
that getting changed because eventually
it'll go back right so I never really
get upset about the fact that things
changing like it's like getting angry
because the Sun set well the good thing
is that it'll rise again here in the
next little while so you know don't be
too upset but you know it's it's it's
intriguing to me but the result here is
that with with all this talk of
conspiracy and this idea that so many
hands were behind the destruction of
Krypton that's what Superman
seeks to basically create here is he he
looked at this and he says this circle
was an organization that was hidden
behind the scenes nobody knew what was
going on and they effectively went
through and just decided the fate of the
universe for themselves right like this
world is a threat that world's not a
threat and in reality you can't have a
singular group out there that operates
secretly behind the scenes controlling
everything it can't work that way that
if there are sentient beings out there
and these sentient beings inhabit a
particular world that in turn they
should have a voice right everybody
should have a voice on the problem with
this is that just because everybody has
a voice doesn't mean everybody's voice
matters everybody has a point to make
that's cool but we ignore the
schizophrenic with aluminum foil on
their head because aliens are spying on
them right we're like okay those guys
don't get a voice they kind of stay over
there and and that's basically it
anybody who comes to you and says like
that person deserves a voice you should
probably question whether or not that
person deserves a voice at all right so
the idea behind this is that it's really
Jonathan Kim who essentially presents
the idea and he says on the planet Earth
we have what's called the United Nations
and the United Nations is basically a
place where like all these different
nations across the world can all simply
come together in meat
near their grievances or talk about
things that need to be done now the
problem of the United Nations is that
it's basically a toothless entity but
you got like the UN forces there's
nobody cares about the human forces you
know they're there they're hippies it's
like whatever man
peacekeepers oh yeah but but the fact
remains that that is coming okay let's
take this concept and let's roll this
over into essentially the galaxy but
like all these different races always
even worlds basically taking the place
of Nations all these different worlds
will have representation on this League
of planets basically this is how it's
all gonna work it's gonna be a copy of
the Earth's United Nations and we're
gonna go forward from there now this is
when you starting to get into the nature
of the problem with Bendis because what
is up happening is that in the middle of
all this you end up having the Legion of
super-heroes who show up now it's cool
to see the lead in return right it's
awesome to see the Legion of
super-heroes here the issue with this is
that it's kind of like we're here
because Jonathan Kent is the one who
basically creates like this perfect
future like everything is going to be
awesome now because of Jonathan Kent and
so we wanted to show him the honor of
bringing him into the future now that
works because you ended up seeing that
way back in the day when Superboy joined
the Legion of super-heroes right they
showed up in the modern day and they
said hey come hang out with us like
you're a real pretty cool guy you know
you can be in the cool kids club and
Superboy was just kinda like okay cool
peace and like bail on his friends and
wait to the future he was a dick it's a
cool thing but it's sort of been is just
kind of riding himself you know out of
out of a hole basically because question
will become like where do you go from
there if you're creating like this
United League of planets basically you
know how's it going to work how's it
gonna function are they all gonna listen
what happens if they make it and it
breaks down and dissolves within like 30
days and then essentially one month
later the whole thing's done and
everybody's back to warring again like
is it actually going to work the cool
thing about this and the benefit of this
is we do get Jonathan Kent going to the
future and basically join in the Legion
of super-heroes now if I'm being honest
with you guys if I'm a betting man this
was really where business is gonna shine
because Bendis is amazing when it comes
to writing teenagers I don't know what
it is but he is super good when it comes
to writing teenagers that's one of the
reasons why I say Binda should have been
writing Shazam
but I guess Jeff Jones really wanted it
but like vinda should have been the one
writing Shazam but and I put Jeff Jones
on Superman put Bendis on on on Shazam
and then just go forward from there
because he would have written one heck
of a story like it would have been
awesome as opposed to Shazam right now
just kind of being the story that just
won't end but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here too comments
explained to make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the Rob
poor if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like
and I will catch you all later purse
[Music]